[Music]  just relax and yep  man I can't wait to cut whatever that is  let's check out that's not that's got  not gonna make it all over I see a big  green screen a ladder and some ducks  yeah they're seagulls or whatever no wow  you know what I call that I call that  tableau first day back from Chicago now  hung over writer wrote that yeah  whatever  get some seagulls and a green screen  we'll figure out the rest  well it's the kind of thing that kills  you and there is no moving very slowly  oh hello there and time we have a show  to do how long is this gonna take hey  Conan couple more hours bro okay well  Alan can you release the feral seagulls  please no no no no no no no no no no  there are wires  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  you  [Applause]